across england there's something in the
air honestly never felt better
you've got my best mate with me right
and it's absolutely mean this was
sheffield after england's women known as
the lionesses thrashed sweden to reach
sunday's euro 2022 final
nationwide screenings like this are
bringing people together in public and
nearly half a million fans have attended
matches so far more than doubling the
figure for the last tournament five
years ago latest football is just a
completely different atmosphere to the
men's it's more i don't know it's family
it's more fun everyone joining in
singing mexican waves and underpinning
the euros there's a whole ecosystem from
the women's super league to
semi-professional clubs like dullig
hamlet here in south london to school
teams hard to believe that for decades
women were barred from competing in a
game that the english football
association called quite unsuitable for
females at grounds up and down the
country women's teams offer the fans
quality football week in week out but
there's no doubt the euros tournament
has opened many more people's eyes and
for clubs like this that can only be a
good thing i've got mates texting me who
have had no interest in women's football
before getting really excited about this
tournament lots of guys as well which is
nice to see people of all ages i was on
my bicycle the other day cycling home
and i was stopped at uh traffic lights
and there was three old men and i could
hear them talking about the england game
that was on the night before and just
things like that that just that for me
is really special in recent years
women's and girls football has really
taken off by 2020 the number taking part
in england had reached almost three and
a half million but there's still a long
way to go before the women earn anywhere
near as much as the men do or make a
living from the sport outside the top
tier
hopefully like with the euros it's going
to bring a little bit more attention to
the game and the women are start getting
a bit more recognition because they do
train really hard it would be nice for
them to be
more accepted as the sports people that
they actually are
as the national team gear up for their
biggest match ever they'll be hoping the
home crowd can give them the edge over
germany but it's not just about the
result we hope that
yeah that we got everyone so
enthusiastic and that at the end
actually the whole country is proud
proud of us and that more even more
girls and boys will start playing
football of course for the lionesses
going one step further than england's
men did last year and lifting the trophy
is the ultimate goal
nadine barber al jazeera london